okay here we are Michael Steele do you
think that a Republican will challenge
Trump for the nomination in 2020
the short answer is no but there will be
probably some someone like a Ben Sasse
senator who will who has been very
critical of the president for quite some
time
and that whether he gets into a direct
what about a little most party well I
mean you know in 1900 you about 1913
1912 Rd split yeah about if 2018 goes
the way that some in the party field it
may given how the public is is really
kind of roiling with all the Trump stuff
yeah you could see someone step up to
try to save the party for 2020 in some
fashion the fact that Roosevelt didn't
win though with the popularity he had I
shows you the difficulties I don't live
in Africa yeah I don't like this but is
it John Kasich that's what I'm saying
somebody like John King well I mean but
like some wheat is funny when you when
you watch the liberal news channels it's
all Republicans like you and Nicole
Wallace and Charlie Sykes and Rick
Wilson Yucko you know Steve Schmidt it's
all we see is a great Republican smart
Republican reasonable reasonable you
think that was the whole party that's
only one percent of our letters over the
game both of the networks play right Fox
has people who are just this much to the
left of center at their at their
liberals and you know the MSNBC has
collected all six remaining same
Republican Richard Clarke what would be
your strategy for dealing with Kim
jong-un talk to him you know the
president said today as people said
they've lost our patience with this man
they haven't sat down on the table with
him no one asks you're right yeah sit
down the day but he's doing this because
he wants some Rodman does it well right
you know yeah I'm rod Metropolis the
difference you know
[Laughter]
that means it's not fair to Dennis room
did you carry out
okay should congressman get a housing
stipends like jason Chaffetz suggested
as we okay he's a congressman from Utah
he retires Bottari and he said I can't
afford it
he was sleeping in his office I mean
they make what do they make it one
hundred and seventy eight thousand a
year and they all share places to its
yes because they have to keep two homes
and yeah and he's not going to go and
get a lucrative contract with some
television network and he'll have cashed
it but I'm sure not just publicly very
supportive of that right the idea not
only did you more members we're always
lecturing poor Americans to live within
their means yeah yeah yeah enjoy about
health care and chase it's Kapus is the
very [ __ ] who said maybe you
shouldn't buy a cell phone and you
should buy health care instead because a
health care plan annually cases also the
one who went on television at least five
times and said he had to distance
himself from Donald Trump after the
Access Hollywood tapes and couldn't
possibly look at fifteen-year-old
daughter in the eye and say that he was
supporting this guy and then turned
around and voted for her oh so luck that
guy okay
we'll have them on the show and his
Chiron will say the very [ __ ]
Dan given the way the Trump
administration is trending on gay rights
do you feel confident telling LGBT youth
that it gets better yeah I mean he was
supposed to be pretty good on the
subject and vivanco was supposed to be a
moderating influence but it doesn't look
too good on that score no it's a there
hasn't been a great large sort of
thunderbolt moment with Trump attacking
LGBTQ civil rights but there's been a
lot of little cuts and it's kind of the
death of a thousand cuts that we're
worried about just today Trump appointed
to the US foreign aid agency a camera
over the name of it to work on gender
equality and gender issues someone who's
an anti trans rights activist so in the
same way that he appointed Betsy DeVos
who opposes public education to have the
depart of education he's opposing
appointing people who have control over
things are going to impact LGBT
Americans all these anti LGBT pickets
including his first pick pence I by the
way I saw headline in the New York Times
it was like on page 14 like buried in
the middle of paper I never did anybody
else talk about it shows you where we
are in perspective wise it said cuts to
aid funding could cost a million lives
but they're not American lives so you
know page 14 who gets a [ __ ] but but
that's an that's what and one of the
first executive orders he signed was a
get with Mexico City rule to rollback
federal funding of abortion providers
and abortion advisors in developing
countries that's already having a huge
impact on women in developing countries
and directly impacting their health
process you know who was great on that
issue George Bush very much so who I'm
in right here right there
quickly entity it gets better question
whether we get it gets better because we
get out there and we fight to make it
better it doesn't get better by itself
right we can sulfated clear you it gets
better we're out here fighting to make
it better join the fight we can make it
better things look pretty dire under
george w bush under ronald reagan and we
there the arc was trending positive
things a pretty dire right now
particularly the supreme court yeah
where people have the most to lose after
women with his appointments to the
Supreme Court and this Gorsuch guy it
was a liar when I testified oh I'm just
going to be a neutral umpire calling
balls and strikes
he's Scalia no into the right words in
the right of Scalia okay Katty Kay what
do you make of the rivalry between Jared
Kushner and Secretary of State Rex
Tillerson you cited him earlier rec as
one of the people we can count on to be
smarten that's amazing where the bar is
now when the head of exon is one of the
guys I think increasingly I'm hearing
the names Madison McMaster balls and I'm
hearing Tillison that you know Jared
Krishna went to the Middle East and it
seems that the 36 year old wonder kid
with no experience in foreign policy
actually won't bring about peace in the
Middle East as quickly as even thought
and then he had a hard time President
Abbas and this is where the rivalry
stems from is that the White House want
to have foreign policy inside what I
listen is discovering and Tillison you
know lost his mind
bless this past week as well it is made
it very clear he wants to hire his own
people he wants to now close that shop
in a little bit more so Kim field but
you lie that it lose his mind well yeah
that's true that's true but I have no
one that has a department I used to be
an Assistant Secretary of State I was
appointed in February
yeah but July they haven't appointed one
of them but but that but that again
that's not the Secretary's fault that is
being held up by the West Wing itself
but the Secretary's folks are waiting
til July to get pissed off well that may
be but I think what's pissing him off
more is taking orders from Jared Kushner
that would be yes I mean he was ahead of
base on it had like a country yeah
the country is taking or take notice
from the son-in-law Breck thank you very
much everybody have a great
[Applause]